there's a couple different methods for
determining whether a function is even
or odd now graphically if you have a
picture of the graph where you can graph
it you can tell it's even if when you
reflect it over the y-axis that it
matches with itself so you can see here
this if you fold this w-shaped graph
it's going to match itself this is even
if you fold this parabola over the
y-axis you see it matches with itself
that's even if you take this absolute
value graph you fold it over the y-axis
it matches with itself it's even so all
three of these top ones are going to be
even function so reflection over the
y-axis that's how you test with odd
functions you want to see if it's a
hundred and eighty degree like a half
turn rotation about the origin if you
rotate this y equals x cubed graph of
around the origin 180 degrees it will
match with itself that tells us that
it's an odd function for this one this
is like the line y equals x again if you
take this graph and you rotate it 180
degrees 1/2 turn it will match with
itself that means it's odd and this
one's like y equals sine of X and again
you can see if you rotate it 180 degrees
in matches with itself so these are
going to be odd functions but
algebraically the way you test it is you
put negative x into your function ok in
place of ax on the right side if you get
the original function back then we call
this an even function meaning if you
graph it it's gonna be reflection over
the y-axis if you put negative x in and
you get the original function back but
it's multiplied by negative one then
that means that it's an odd function
which means it's a rotation about the
origin like these bottom three ones here
so let's go through some examples these
are some typical ones that you'll see in
your class for number one f of X equals
two times the absolute value of X minus
four so our test is we're going to put
negative x in in place of X we know when
you take the absolute value of a
negative quantity or a positive quantity
you end up getting that positive
quantity so this is really going to be
the same as two times absolute value of
x minus 4 you can see we're getting back
the original function the original
equation when we plugged in that
negative x that tells us that this is
going to be an even function ok let's
look at number two this one here again
same process all you're doing is you're
wherever you see X just put negative x
in so this is going to be two
x negative x squared minus one but when
you have a negative squared that's going
to be the same thing as a positive right
so the negative times a negative is a
positive so that's the same as two x
squared minus one times negative x now
you can see this whole equation here
it's just like the original function we
had it's just now it's multiplied by
negative one and that tells us that it's
an odd function meaning it's going to be
a rotation around the origin okay number
three the same idea we're just going to
replace X with negative x wherever you
see that X put in negative x and the key
is to put it in parenthesis so you take
it as a group but if you have a negative
to an odd power that's gonna make it
negative if you have a negative to an
even power that's gonna make this
quantity positive but then times
negative three of course is negative
when we look at this is it the same as
the original function definitely not if
we factor out a negative one like this
we get 2x cubed plus 3x squared minus
four does this look like the original
equation no it doesn't if it did and it
was just multiplied by negative 1 that
would be odd this one is actually
neither even or odd okay
for number four we've got some
fractional exponents rational exponents
same process we're replacing X with
negative x right and remember to switch
this into radical form the denominator
is the root the numerator is the power
but think about it when you have a cube
root or the fifth root of the seventh
degree of a negative number that's just
going to be the same as negative
whatever this quantity is here right so
like if you had the cube root of
negative 8 that just going to be a
negative 2 it's gonna be a negative
number and then multiply by this 10 here
this is gonna make this a negative 10
okay let me just move this down here
negative 10 and then this quantity here
is raised to the 4th power right so you
can see running up with negative 10
times X to the fourth fist power it's
the same as the original function but
see how it's multiplied by negative 1
that means that this is going to be an
odd function and then the last example
number 5 same process for replacing X
with negative x again notice how I'm
putting it in parentheses to keep
everything organized negative to an odd
power is going to be negative so this is
just going to be like like that now
Megan gives you a positive so if we
simplify all this down we get X to the
fifth plus X plus one and you can see
it's not the same as the original
function if we factor out a negative one
we get negative x to the fifth negative
X minus one and does that look like the
original function no it does not because
see positive one negative ones so it's
not odd so this one is neither and
you've got it if you want to see more
examples with even and odd functions
follow me over to the video right there
again this channel is all about making
learning math less stressful for you if
you like my teaching style go ahead and
subscribe to the channel and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos